et
voilà la rencontre entre jacqueline
gourault et brigitte deveza puisque je
vous le disais jacqueline gourault elle
connaît bien ce groupe union centriste
auquel vous venez adhérer pascal en a et
ses monuments pendant des années elle y
reviendra peut-être d'ailleurs jacques
humour ce groupe union centriste
bah si possible c'est possible
le pénis de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales merci beaucoup d'être
notre invité folie merci matin on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour stéphane
bern et le jour stéphane qui dirige le
bureau parisien du journal ouest france
on va parler de vos d'aussi évidemment
jacqueline gourault ils sont nombreux
mais d'abord emmanuel macron wallon
prendre la parole ce soir à 20 heures il
était attendu par les français alors que
les cas de co vide remonte dans le pays
est ce que ce sera un discours de
remobilisation autour des gestes
barrières d'appel à la vaccination
puisqu'on ne voit qu'elle patine un peu
ou est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à des
annonces de la part du chef de l'état
bien sûr ce sera d'abord une
intervention sur la mobilisation
nécessaire par rapport effectivement au
taux d'incidence qui remonte dans de
plus de soixante départements
et rappelle donc qu'il faille qu'il faut
pardon
c'est un genou gauche en train de faire
un rappel qu'il faut faire des rappels
excusez moi
ah
bon
c'est la nécessité évidemment d'avoir
cette troisième dose pour les plus de 70
ans en priorité mais aussi pour les
autres générations car on sait que cette
protection est nécessaire
le rappelle aussi des gestes barrières
il faut continuer à faire ce que nous
faisons depuis des mois et porter de
masque
ne pas avoir trop des changes tactile
avec les gens utilisent et du gel et
c'est très important alors peut-être
pour préciser les choses il n'y a pas
pour l'instant et nous espérons que nous
éviterons de crise hospitalière
le nombre de personnes hospitalisées est
autour de 1000 ce qui est faible par
rapport à d'autres pays et le taux
d'incidence est aussi très inférieur à
ce qu'on ne connaît l'allemagne ou
l'angleterre est naturellement cela est
dû à la couverture vaccinale qui a été
beaucoup plus importante en france est
ce que votre connaissance le chef de
l'état évoquera d'autres sujets par
exemple chaud des réformes sur de la fin
du championnat ou et bien je n'ai pas
connaissance des autres sujets que
pourrait aborder le président de la
république vous pensé tu devrais le
faire à ce stade là je pense que la
priorité pour le président de la
république s'est naturellement la crise
sanitaire vous savez chaque semaine
nous avons bien sûr un conseil des
ministres
et chaque semaine le président de la
république commence par faire le point
sur la crise sanitaire que ce soit dans
les périodes
où la crise était très forte ou même
actuellement dans une période où la
crise est beaucoup moins forte où il y a
bien sûr encore des risques mais c'est
chaque semaine et qu'est-ce qui vous dit
alors ces dernières semaines et ce cas
une inquiétude quand même de la part du
chef de l'état ben oui bien sûr enfin
une inquiétude c'est peut-être c'est un
rappel de la nécessité d'être vigilant
c'est ça la permanence de sa position on
a reçu plusieurs maires on en reçoit
régulièrement vous le savez dans cette
émission qui nous disent mais on
aimerait bien savoir s'il faut qu'on se
prépare à relancer une campagne d'être
de troisième dose nous on a été
évidemment très mobilisés pendant la
crise sanitaire on a besoin
d'information est ce que ce matin vous
dit au maire mais oui préparez-vous il
va y avoir une campagne est large il va
falloir repartir d'abord on n'est plus
dans la même situation parce que on n'a
pas autant de gens à vacciner une
protection qui est très importante et
puis on a changé aussi les méthodes de
vaccination on a ouvert davantage par
exemple la vaccination chez les
pharmaciens et c'est très facile
aujourd'hui au delà de d'octo libre chez
les professionnels de santé que sont les
médecins d'aller chez d'autres
professionnels seront plus autant je ne
dis pas ça mais je souhaite évidemment
alors il y encore des centres de
vaccination quand vous passez vous
promener en france vous voyez centres de
vaccination ici ou là mais on n'est pas
dans la pression qu'on a connue mais il
se peut qu'on ait besoin de faire appel
effectivement à nouveau à des centres de
vaccination plus importants et dans ce
cas comme par le passé on s'appuiera
bien sûr sur les mères qui ont un joué
un rôle considérable
alors quand on est dans la vaccination
mais je crois que le président de la
république va que s'est exprimé ce soir
est un vrai prince qu'il convient de
parler des maires il ya au bout
également quinze présidents socialistes
de département tu as écrit au premier
ministre pour leur dire que ne voulait
pas assumer la hausse des dépenses de
rsa liées au personnel de santé ou aux
salariés en fait qui étaient suspendues
du fait de leur non vaccination en
l'absence de passe qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce que vous pensez de 7,7 cette prise de
position
je pense plusieurs choses d'abord je
pense étonnant de la part de la gauche
c'est un peu à fronts renversés et si on
permettait de ne pas être dans la
solidarité
avec les professionnels de santé c'est
un peu surprenant pour votre d'autorité
dit ça va créer une inégalité
républicaine où ils ces personnes
suspendues et les quatre qui sont bien
payés c'est pas normal qu'ils soient
locataires du rsp il y a en france
d'abord c'est qu'elle est quelle est la
situation ses preuves ces professionnels
de santé sont en suspension de contrat
parce que c'est il faut être très clair
mais la loi en france est aussi très
clair toute personne qui ne reçoit aucun
salaire aucune indemnité rien du tout a
droit effectivement au rsa et
il est il est clair que ce n'est pas non
plus légion de personnes qui vont aller
demander
le rsa je pense que c'est une affaire
qui a été
à l'est plus politique de la part des
présidents de conseils généraux
que une affaire véritablement de fonds
vous en avez parlé avec eux non je n'ai
pas eu l'occasion
d'en parler alors que hier j'étais dans
l'aude il ya une présidente du conseil
départemental
socialiste je ne sais plus si elle s il
en a pas pas là et s'ils vont lever
recel
écoutez je crois que ce n'est pas un
problème majeur je crois que les
professionnels de santé d'abord dans
leur la plupart des cas on réfléchit à
certain nombre sont se font vacciner et
ce n'est pas la poignée de ceux qui sont
les derniers résistants qui vont faire
basculer le régime du rsa c'est pas une
façon aussi de relancer le vieux débat
sur le la non compensation à 100 % des
dépenses oui alors là département paris
on peut même je dirais être surpris que
le département de seine-saint-denis et
signé
7 l'une dans la mesure où nous avons
passé un accord de recentralisation du
rsa avec le président un accord qui a
donné lieu à des négociations et un
accord
signé et qui convient tout à fait à la
fois à l'état et à monsieur le président
de la de seine-saint-denis donc
en l'occurrence
si tel était le cas des professionnels
de santé de seine-saint-denis à partir
de l'année prochaine ce serait l'état
qui paieraient on va parler des mères
puisque le congrès des maires a lieu la
semaine prochaine évidemment c'est le
rendez vous annuel des maires de france
parmi les demandes des maires ça
concerne la crise sanitaire c'est être
compensé à 100 % du coût de cette crise
sanitaire pour les communes vous allez
dire oui
les choses ont été très claires dès le
départ et quand vous dites les maires
demandent
bon peut-être c'est par la voix de
françois baroin oui c'est ça c'est ce
que j'allais vous dis non c'est ce que
je veux dire c'est l'association des
maires de france
moi je suis une ministre qui vais qui va
beaucoup sur le terrain je sais ce nom
les maires me parle et ce dont ils ne
parlent jamais alors certes peut-être
parce que je suis pas ministre de la
santé il n'aborde pas ce sujet mais
enfin c'est pas quelque chose qu'il me
réclame
en permanence car en effet d'abord les
maires considèrent qu'ils ont fait leurs
devoirs républicains
tout simplement en organisant les
centres de vaccination
contraire oui oui bien sûr est de
l'ordre de 5 à 6 milliards et qu'au
moment du quoi qu'il en coûte il
trouvait ça normal que les maires soient
bien les maires sont compensées il ya un
accord qui a été
comment dire une décision je ne veux pas
dire accord une décision qui a été prise
par le ministère de la santé c'est
d'indemniser les communes sur les
surcoûts parce que de quoi s'agit-il il
s'agit souvent de prêter une salle il
s'agit peut-être de construire des
espèces de barnum et puis surtout de
mettre du personnel et quand le
personnel travaille à la mairie il est
naturellement payer et s'il est dans un
centre de vaccination
c'est la mairie qui continue à le payer
par contre si il y à des permanences le
week-end ou des heures supplémentaires
c'est l'état qui prend en charge
conclura pas de mesures supplémentaires
sur cette question que ce qui avait
coûté aujourd'hui je rappelle aussi que
nous avons remboursé la moitié de
la consommation delà de ce qui a été
fait pour les masques du port du masque
et l'état a compensé les collectivités
territoriales à propos du congrès des
maires la semaine prochaine est ce que
vous savez si le chef de l'état
prononcera un discours à la fin du
congrès comme les années précédentes et
vous même est ce que vous vous y rendre
et alors bien sûr j'irai au congrès des
maires
parce que c'est comment dire ma mission
et j'aurais sur la partie
espace où sont rassemblés tous les
exposants
le ministère aura un stand
important avec l' agence nationale de
cohésion des territoires et avec la
direction générale des collectivités
locales nous aurons un grand stand et
nous ferons des échanges nous avons des
thématiques qui sont organisés et nous
accueillerons les maires par contre je
n'ai pas été invités cette année à
participer à une table ronde au congrès
c'est normal ça
c'est normal ou si ça n'est pas normal
mais effectivement c'est un peu
surprenant c'est la ministre
en charge des collectivités
territoriales soit pas invitée à
participer un débat mais bon ce qui est
important c'est que je sais qui
je sais qu'il ya des débats qui gît
conquis qui vont avoir lieu sur les
contrats de relancer transition
écologique tout ce qui dépend de mon
ministère j'en suis fort heureuse mais
on ne m'a pas demandé d'y participer le
chef de l'état ira conclure son congrès
oui bien sûr le premier ministre aussi
le fera comme habituellement le label ou
ans je n'ai pas dit mais je le premier
ministre a sûrement présent au concret
on va parler de la loi décentralisation
lallaoui avec une question toute simple
donc elle a été étudié cet été au sénat
transformer compléter elle devait passer
à l'assemblée au mois de septembre elle
est reportée à décembre est ce que ce
calendrier sera tenu oui c'est sûr donc
elle sera bien est examiné à l'assemblée
au moins deux abris a plaisamment
encore du cd les rapporteurs sont en
train de faire les auditions j'ai des
dates pour aller participer aux
différentes commissions concernées et la
date précise dans l'hémicycle c'est le 6
décembre
stéphane le disait elle a été modifiée
transformé par le par le sénat est ce
que vous allez conserver tous les
apports du sénat où est ce qu'il ya des
choses que ça regarde mal beaucoup
grossi cette loi alors oui il est venu
3d savez
c'est pas une nouveauté qu'une loi sur
les collectivités territoriales
grossistes au sénat voilà le projet il y
avait quoi 83 article m 1,7 voilà plus
de deux cents à la wii récemment alors
bon je l'appelais une fois l'expérience
du sénat que j'ai ne je ne m'attendais
pas à autre chose d'abord liée à des
choses qui sont effectivement positives
qui ont été rajoutés par le sénat ya
beaucoup de thématiques sur lesquelles
il ya eu un débat très intéressant je
pense par exemple au logement qui était
c'est elle cette partie portée
par aussi bien sûr emmanuelle wargon a
été très intéressante et enrichissante
de vous dire que nous allons tout garder
certainement pas puisque il ya des
choses sur lesquelles vous le savez bien
l'état et le gouvernement n'était pas
favorable
et donc il ya des choses sur lesquelles
nous avons nous allons revenir il ya
toujours vraiment sur la question de l
île et à tous oui bien sûr et il y a
aussi toujours ce sujet qui fait débat
c'est l'intercommunalité les compétences
de l'intercommunalité et des communes
c'est toujours un débat important
elle est trop loin là dessus pour vous
il ya une inquiétude oui
oui il y a par exemple la dcf qui est
très inquiète enfin je devrais changer
le nom puisque maintenant il s'appelle
intercommunalités de france je crois
là j'étais évidemment vous intermittents
quand j'étais invité au congrès france
urbaine présidée par la maire de nantes
est aussi où j'étais aussi et est aussi
inquiète notamment d'un certain nombre
de choses qui kiffent hercules pour
l'intercommunale exagérément optimiste
sur un accord entre députés et sénateurs
ça veut dire que vous vous dites cette
fois elle entrera en vigueur avant la
fin du quinquennat
j'espère beaucoup d'abord parce que il
ya plein de points sur lesquels on est
d'accord on insiste toujours sur les
points sur lesquels on n'est pas
d'accord mais il ya plein de points sur
lesquels on est d'accord il y a des
choses qui étaient dans les 50
propositions
que le sénat avait fait qu'ils ont été
reprises pas tout mais un grand nombre
et puis nous avons des rapporteurs
françoise gatel et et mathieu darnaud
qui sont des rapporteurs sur une autre
en connaissent très bien les
collectivités locales et avec qui je
dois dire nous avions eu un débat tout à
fait constructif au sénat c'est la
raison pour laquelle aussi
la loi a pu continuer son chemin un
dernier mot sur cette loi au début du
quinquennat emmanuel macron il avait
parlé d'une grande loi de
décentralisation là vous le dites vous
même c'est pas une grande loi de
décentralisation c'est plutôt une loi
technique est ce que cette grande loi de
décentralisation elle doit voir le jour
dans le prochain quinquennat pour vous
ou est-ce que c'est pas possible de
faire ça alors on va jouer un petit peu
vous reprendre au début du quinquennat
le président de la république
n'avait pas annoncé de grandes oies
décentralisation
nous étions sur la ligne qui durait pas
de grandes
lloret nom qui aurait pas de grande loi
sur les collectivités territoriales dans
la mesure où
les élus réclament et cela parce qu'il y
avait eu beaucoup beaucoup de lois dans
les années 90 la loi madame la loi notre
le droit découpage des régions le
changement d'élections sur les cantons
il y avait eu beaucoup beaucoup et il a
changé en dix langues mais la renommée
il n'avait jamais même demandé les
arrêtait pas de grandes lois sur
territoriale puis comme vous savez il y
a eu le phénomène
contestataires gd gilet jaune qui a fait
que après que le président de la
république et c'est le grand débat il a
pensé nécessaire effectivement qu'on
revienne sur un certain nombre de choses
et il a parlé effectivement à ce moment
là d'une loi de décentralisation et tout
le travail que j'ai fait de concertation
j'ai vu ou bien un 2000 et lui sur la
france entière nous a enrichi le texte
aussi de ces de ce souhait de
simplification de déconcentration et de
différenciation c'est-à-dire de respect
des territoires qui est importante a
parlé du temps de travail des
fonctionnaires autre sujet oui la loi
sur la fonction publique de 2019 en fait
impose aux communes de passer aux 35
heures de travail hebdomadaire à partir
du 1er janvier 2022 or il existe tout un
système de dérogation qui fait quand en
moyenne les les agents territoriaux sont
plus toi dans les communes sont plutôt
en moyenne à 32 heures et non à 35 vous
avez plupart des villes qui se sont
adaptés qui se prépare à passer aux 35
heures réelles pour leur argent sauf
quelques unes dont la ville de paris
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous pouvez
faire pour peaufiner le mans ou
contraindre ces collectivités à
appliquer la loi bah il faut appliquer
la loi parce que la loi le texte de
dit que
le 1er janvier 2022 pour les communes et
les intercommunalités
et 2023 pour les départements et les
régions doivent appliquer la loi et donc
ils doivent appliquer la loi et vous
fait si ce n'est pas le cas puisque vous
voyez qu'il ya des communes qui trouve
d'un système dérogatoire avec des jours
de congés
la
journée du carnaval oui mais ça tout ça
on connaissait depuis longtemps moi il y
avait la journée des gens qui en
auraient cher à l'époque que je me
souviens
au printemps
imposé quelles seront les sanctions ça à
écouter quand on écoute et il y à une
loi et j'espère que les élus sont assez
responsables
pour l'appliquer surtout quand il y as
contestation que ça passe au tribunal
administratif qu'on lui donne tort donc
je pense que les les maires vont
comprendre que c'est une question
d'équité également par rapport à
l'ensemble des citoyens français et des
travailleurs français sur le l'allusion
est à ruminer administratif ces jeux
précisément pour la ville de paris oui
ça ça vous faites référence du mans qui
emploie 50000 agents territoriaux c'est
quand même très c'est quand même
considérable c'est considérable mais
enfin écoutez la maire de paris qui est
par ailleurs candidate
à l'élection présidentielle je ne vois
pas comment elle ne peut pas faire
appliquer la loi lundi que la pas le
temps que se trouve mais c'est pas aller
ya longtemps que 2019 s'est il ya deux
ans
il entend la baisse du nombre de
fonctionnaires puisque vous entendez ça
revient un peu dans le débat notamment
pour le congrès des républicains il ya
certains candidats qui propose de
baisser le nombre de fonctionnaires
c'est aussi une proposition d' emmanuel
macron cette vaisselle aux
fonctionnaires et notamment le nombre de
fonctionnaires territoriaux il avait
promis 70 mille fonctionnaires
territoriaux - ça n'a pas été tenue il
reconnaît tout on le reconnaît dans la
majorité est ce que pour vous il ya trop
de fonctionnaires dans ce pays est ce
que lors du prochain quinquennat il faut
baisser le nombre de fonctionnaires est
ce que ça sera l'engagement du mois je
suis pas de celles qui
réclament à cor et à cris en permanence
le moine fonctionnaires parce que les
français quand vous leur dites il faut
moins de fonctionnaires un certain
nombre 18 puis après quand vous leur
dites enfin quand vous entendez il faut
plus de personnel dans les hôpitaux il
faut pas fermer des classes etc etc donc
je veux dire là comment dire donc non
caractère
supprimant les fonctionnaires dans un
pays où l'état a toujours joué un rôle
très important alors après faut savoir
où il sont les fonctionnaires et c'est
certainement pas sur le terrain qu'il
faut supprimer les fonctionnaires et
certainement pas au plus près des
citoyens c'est à dire dans les
départements puisque c'est au fond la
structure de proximité et on le voit par
exemple
puisque on parle des mers et je suis
ministre des collectivités territoriales
les maires déplore la diminution des
fonctionnaires sur le terrain dans
certains services je pense par exemple
les services techniques qui accompagnent
souvent les mères dans leur projet et
c'est une réalité et le premier ministre
et le premier ministre précédent on
l'avait fait également à une politique
de plutôt de remettre des fonctionnaires
sur le terrain alors après qu au niveau
central dans les ministères il y ait un
peu de grain à moudre ça c'est fort
possible une attention à une question
politique pour terminer on aimerait
avoir des nouvelles la maison commune
qui devra être qui doit voir le jour fin
novembre alors ce sera quel modèle une
grande et belle villa tout confort où
une auberge espagnole
écoutez je pense que ce sera
en tout cas une maison dans laquelle
l'esprit de concorde de pluralisme aussi
de respect des histoires de chacun
d'entre nous
sera
prédominant est en tout cas un esprit
d'union un esprit
2 comment dire républicain et qui
permettra de préparer l'avenir et
sûrement quand il l'aura décidé de
soutenir le président de la république à
l'élection présidentielle le 28 novembre
pour nous confirmer sa date non je vous
confirme rien du tout françois bayrou
avait dit avant noël ce sera je crois
dans nos annales mais pas le 28 novembre
on a compris merci avec humour merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin
[Musique]